welcome to this video I'm playing night
jump my jump from the US I guess
sometimes it's tricky and there are some
stars and stripes or let's say this
stripes like the data somewhat similar
okay he played a quick Bishop e3 hmm so
some way to use that probably not what
about c5 is it an idea hmm to get the C
porn involved come on let's let's play
in this modern type of fashion with the
e5 coming being out of theoretical water
spin move is also interesting for once
okay let's see what is he doing now
maybe c3 just builds during the center I
can consider to play C thrillin d5 maybe
not not at all interesting
hmm
okay yeah well Bishop d7 hero if you
care if he plays d5 we have a trade of
my bad Bishop and I good Bishop but ok
not much they can do about it and it's
not so terrible with the quick f5 oh ok
it's this I didn't expect so it's not
bad i mean you can do that he's got the
quick c4 c5 coming ok so um how should I
play this I I could at this at this
exact moment i could play Bishop h6 get
rid of the dark squared Bishop maybe now
I can go with that five yeah come on
let's get rid of this this problem peace
as long it's still possible Bishop age 6
i've got queen eh forecheck important
trick always on if the f porn is moved
you
the downside is that it is very slow we
plays a move like Knight c3 here which
looks very natural yeah check that's
also not so good all this takes lots of
time okay so we have a typical position
closed type of position okay well I
cannot play without f5 anyway so better
get it get it in as some soon as
possible
yeah I wonder how to continue that's an
interesting yeah he's got to be 45 of
course I wonder if I should man I don't
know a five is probably not a good idea
it's weakening the queenside in the long
run and at the moment it's not yeah
maybe here here i can consider it yeah
because the a file opens up i don't
think that before as was Gordon
brilliant could could have been could
have been better timing
you may you might play b-52 just just
trying to shut down everything
maybe that's actually better than a
three or a three I will take care it's
not like the great move but maybe maybe
that's really better okay um how do I
continue here my idea is to open up
their farm and I want to wait until he
has played 92 so 90 to take and then
I've got 94 93 this kind of idea coming
I don't want to play b6 yet freezing up
the queenside there might be some
chances if I if I am keep it like that
and now this is an interesting spot
Bishop h3 yes he might play be six
though takes 94 no and I this is good I
just go here and get the get the F fine
under control and it's not so easy for
him now to play what should why do
there's no g4 also coming
I'm wondering about b6 really maybe you
should do that getting getting
counterplay like take night a 4 but I
have the ship g2 as well I'm threatening
b6 now I really think that that is a
positional threat if I shut down the
queenside completely I'm probably just
winning with nijah for Brooke f 3 i'm
just invading here on the light squares
or maybe c5 know that that's too slow um
I will I will just shut this down here
maybe from a technical point of view 94
something was better but this is just a
good human move it keeps the queenside
closed and now I'm I'm just pushing
things forward on the kingside a simple
a plan is rook on f2 and like Bishop g2
night h 2 i'm just winning the h-bond
and i can also improve with moves like
rook f3 first then rook f8 yeah that's
the dream position really very nice
it's quite surprising how quickly this
went downhill yeah he does not see him a
good move which is understandable really
I can first improve our pieces look a to
f 82 f 3 yeah that's awesome surprising
really oh that one I didn't I didn't
consider that move at all okay yes the
lab could control a three is attacked
cannot go night e3 or f2 and I just have
look to f8 the AAA droop coming up next
sometimes is also let's say place night
dd1 to see three back this also the move
Knight III just attacking see form and
it's a basically impossible to protect
and we were looking all kinds of museum
as weird as it looks but this is a move
I've got I should have at least
considered it and it's not really a
problem because of rook f1 but still I
didn't think of it at all
yeah now this Bishop g2 threatened
winning the rook
yeah Bishop g2 is probably dead lame and
I don't really see a move he's got
everything on the first rank okay rook
the other rook here I guess
so that Bishop g2 is a real threat
okay so I'm just real age too i guess on
is there better mood roca f2 yeah we f2f
17 probably also great yeah I'll take it
checked and now ruka three would be
would be made but there is the night on
g5 if I just attack the night just
attack the 996 this rook f3 and made
into yeah check checkmate yeah this went
downhill surprisingly quickly really
quickly so let's let's check i mean i
don't think i'm in diamond bed bad shape
here but i was thinking it's it's
probably about equal yeah this is
probably isn't isn't really really
fitting to the position yeah and it's
may be here already you must be very
precise this this is losing you yeah
the computer wants to play a king feel
like this in order to recapture with the
night keeping their fire closed this is
not particularly attractive for white
but he must do that there's really no
alternative in the game after this I'm
winning simply I'm winning the whole
kicking side and invading on the light
squares and to be success the only only
kind of try to make it difficult takes
Andrew P oneness the computer suggestion
funny enough it wants to play rook a6
here ok 6 i'm not sure that he would
have fled at one well i don't know if it
is the only move yeah well if you you
can you can put up the logic that this
is a rook attacking the porn and it's a
rook defending so it's not so ridiculous
on a six it gives a black a complete win
here with noisy for Luke f3 coming but
still it looks a bit strange with a sec
that's what you should have tried and ta
be six is just shutting down any counter
play and now it's it's a one-way street
yeah and it's it's just it's just lost
its no way that white can prevent this
this threat interesting really I guess
some
maybe around T I can't play a bit more
ambitiously like like do it like that I
don't really have anything better than
to capture myself and in general this
kind of positions on my white has the
space advantage it's quite good to have
more pieces on the board as usual with
an etchant space more pain more pieces
are favoring the side that has more
space so we maybe shouldn't exchange
yeah change all of that it's not like
white is lost or anything but it's it's
not it's not helping much also hear ye
exchanged himself if you consider 93 for
example what is memories now maybe I can
play a five maybe but other than that I
would probably change myself okay maybe
he considered the night to be misplaced
on age six but it turned out that it was
coming to g4 later with good effect yeah
interesting how quickly this went down
the drain alright thanks for watching